[Music]
you look like a video girl woman mmm
feel good you look good
marsala dejeuner our head of hair he
just nailed that way orange is a tricky
color but I did this hombre kind of
creamsicle wig I thought that it came
out okay
I was like all right and she like can
wear anything any look you put on a lot
of she liked it braces it embodies
whatever it is more alike thanks for
nothing
every day is like really funny the girls
are always in great spirit anyone that
has an idea no funny wins
so yeah whatever idea you have that's
cool like they're willing to try it and
go with it it's cool that they're not
afraid to look weird just like some jobs
it's always about being beautiful or
whatever and with this it's like like
you said funny wins thank you very much
wow those are dangerous oh but they do
come in handy my dear friend may made
these nails she's an incredible nail
artist this episode is all about Ilona
eating money making money and needing to
play hard cuz she worked so hard
a chair a light too so part of that is
expressed through her nail
which are dollar signs in like you know
dollar bill font theme and then Barack
and Michelle on the ring fingers then
the toes in the tag the fourth act just
also called the turn the big toes are
sasha and malia
I hope the Obamas are honored no fair on
earnest
[Music]